California governor Gavin Newsom taking
aim at his Red State rivals for their
focus on culture issues like parental
rights I think these culture wars have
gone too far at the same time I don't
criticize those poor parents out there
that have been ginned up there's a lot
of misunderstanding misrepresentation
out there because people are weaponizing
these grievances against vulnerable
communities led by DeSantis led by Sarah
Huckabee Sanders
led by Greg Abbott they have a zest for
demonization but this is why California
is so essential this is why we matter
and now he's touting the Golden State as
the freedom State as a new bill
prohibits school districts from Banning
books but right now in California there
are parents fighting the state and
Courts for the right to know what is
going on with their children in the
classrooms let's bring in Dave Rubin
host of the Rubin report Dave
explain that one to me
the freedom state
the fact well the fact that this guy can
even say the word freedom without
bursting out into laughter in and of
itself is hilarious Sandra as you know I
left California very publicly during
covet I brought two companies and over a
dozen employees here to the actually
free state of Florida California has
also purged about a million people in
three years who have largely almost
exclusively moved to Red States because
people want more freedom they don't want
to be locked down and injected with
things they want to know what their kids
are going to be taught they don't want
state employees secretly talking to
their children about gender transition
or any of this other stuff and Gavin
Newsom you know this idea that somehow
it's the red States and the Republicans
and of course DeSantis who's his real
opponent here that somehow they are the
ones instigating the culture wars no
it's the blue States it's the leftists
and liberals the teachers and the
Democrats who are pushing all of this
gender nonsense this hyper racialization
this absolute lie that America is
systemically racist they're pushing this
on everyone's children they're pushing
Dei into all of our institutions and our
schools Etc and then he turns around and
says oh it's the mean Republicans when
all the it's not even Republicans I
would say it's mostly disaffected
liberals look what happened with Glenn
junkin's election in Virginia it's not
that these were all Republicans voting
for him these were parents who got
mugged by reality and thus voted
Republican so all the let's say
right-leaning people are doing the same
people are just pushing back on the
extremism that he puts a very slimy face
to
um this was from the governor's office
there in California on the true Freedom
state California is the the true Freedom
state it reads a place where families
not politics political Fanatics have the
freedom to decide what is right for them
with the passage of legislation to ban
Banned Book Bans
and ensure all students have textbooks
our state's family agenda is now even
stronger to your point you'd have to
explain if it's the freedom State why so
many people are fleeing that state
here's parents Sonia Shaw from last week
on parental rights listen
you know our kids can't even take a
Tylenol without our permission but yet
he's picking and choosing what he wants
us parents to know and I think that
sends the message down that they have a
clear agenda they want control of our
children and she said she's hearing that
frustration from parents from both sides
of the aisle in that state David
well it's rather extraordinary what he's
saying here because you know that just
yesterday the senate had a hearing on
the supposed book bans and Senator John
Kennedy from Louisiana started reading
from one of these books that are that
are being read to third and fourth and
fifth graders and it's so pornographic
that you guys can't show it on Fox News
so it can't be read even red not even
just the images the words would not be
allowed to be said on cable news but
somehow Gavin Newsom thinks that
elementary school kids should hear these
things I'm interviewing Michelle later
today and we'll unpack this further but
again these are not radicals or
extremists or Maga Republicans these are
parents who just want to revert to an
education that we got for Generations in
America and then somehow in the last 20
or 30 years we've completely let go of
and that a world where parents have the
ultimate say in their child's life and
what is happening in the classroom thank
you so much for joining us on that and
we'll look forward to your interview
with Michelle as well